in this video you're going to learn how
to graph exponential functions using
Transformations we're going to go
through three examples together once you
get the hang of this see if you can try
some of these problems on your own
let's dive in so when we talk about an
exponential function it's a function
that's in this form y equals a times B
to the x minus H Power Plus K and when
you look at this B this is what's
referred to the base it's below the
exponent here and when the base is
greater than zero and the base can't be
one but if it's greater than zero it
tells us that it's an exponential growth
function meaning it's going up to the
right like this it's going to have a
horizontal asymptote right here like so
if the base is between 0 and 1 it's
going to be an exponential decay
function meaning it's going down to the
right it's decaying now the a value this
coefficient here when you take the
absolute value of a if it's greater than
1 then we say it's like a vertical
stretch like you're pulling it in the y
direction vertically but if the absolute
value of a is in between 0 and 1 say
like a half then we say it's a vertical
shrink okay so you're squeezing it
vertically and if the a value is less
than 0 meaning it's negative it's going
to reflect it over the x-axis so it's a
reflection the H and K are going to
shift the graph so this one's going to
shift it left and right and the K is
going to shift it up and down just kind
of keep in mind though this x minus H
like if it's x minus 2 it actually
shifts it to the right two if it's X
plus 2 it goes to the left 2. so it's
like the opposite of the sign whereas
the K value if that's plus 2 it does go
up to positive 2 if it's negative 2 it
does go down to and then y equals K is
going to be where our horizontal
asymptote is so let's take a look at the
first example y equals 2 times 3 to the
x minus 1 plus 2. let's start by
focusing on the parent function the
parent function is just this part right
here the equation y equals 3 to the X
power let's make a table just on that
core function pick some easy small
numbers like negative 1 0 and 1. 3 to
the negative 1 is 1 3 because when you
raise something to the first Power it's
itself but a negative you take the
reciprocal that's how we get the one
third three to the zero anything to the
zero power is always one and then three
to the first Power anything to the first
power is itself
so this is kind of like our basic
function but then the 2 is going to be a
vertical stretch by a factor of 2 which
is going to multiply all these y values
by 2. so we're going to have 2 3 2 and
6. I'll just cross out those old y
values
and then the minus 1 is going to shift
the graph not
-1 but to the right one has like the
opposite effect when it's grouped with
the X like that so going right one means
we're going to be adding 1 to all these
X values
cross out the old ones and then the plus
2 is going to shift the graph up 2 which
means I'm going to add 2 to all the Y
values so this is going to be 2 and 2 3
4 and 8. I'll cross out those old y
values now if we plot these points 0
2 and 2 3 would put us right here
1 4
put us right here and 2 8 would put us
right
about here and notice this 2 here this
is our horizontal asymptote y equals two
so you can draw that line in there and
zero graph is going to be an exponential
growth it's going up to the right like
that
uh and it's approaching the horizontal
asymptote as you go to the left so the
domain would be all real numbers the
graph goes to the left forever and ever
and to the right forever and ever and
our range is going to be Y is greater
than 2.
let's take a look at another example
okay in example number two we have y
equals negative one-half to the X plus
two power minus one now to graph this
one let's focus in on the parent
function just the B to the X power so in
this case we're looking at just this
part here y equals one half to the X
power let's make a table and just pick
some easy small numbers negative one
zero and one
one half to the negative one remember
that negative exponent you take the
reciprocal so this is going to come out
to 2. one half to the zero remember
anything to the zero power is one and
then anything to the first power is
itself so that's going to be one half
now let's go ahead and look at this a
value here so the a value is doing what
it's reflecting it over the x-axis
because this is negative when you
reflect it over the x-axis you're
multiplying all the Y values by negative
one so this is going to become negative
2 negative one
and negative one-half
cross out the old y values the plus 2 is
going to shift the graph not to the
right two but negative 2 to the left 2.
so that means I'm going to subtract 2
from all of these X values cross out the
old ones and then the minus 1 is going
to shift the graph down one which is
going to affect the Y values so I'm
going to subtract 1 from each of these
y values cross out the old ones let's go
ahead and graph this so we have negative
3 negative 3
which is going to put us right about
here
and negative 2 negative 2 right about
and negative 1 negative one and a half
which is right about here and then
notice this K value y equals negative 1
is going to be our horizontal
asymptote right there so you can see
what's happening this graph is looking
something like this
it's getting closer and closer to that
horizontal asymptote domain is all real
numbers but the range is going to be Y
is less than negative 1. and our
horizontal asymptote here is y equals
negative 1. now originally see this
graph y equals one half to the X it's an
exponential decay function it would look
like this but then what happened is we
reflected it over the x-axis so now it
looks something like this
and then we're shifting it left to down
one that's how we're getting this graph
let's take a look at one last example
see if you can try example number three
on your own go ahead and pause the video
f of x equals one half times four to the
x minus 3 power minus three how would
you graph that one well if I was going
to do it I would start off by focusing
in on this parent function y equals 4 to
the X power so if we go ahead and do
some easy numbers negative one zero and
one four to the negative 1 is 1 4.
4 to the 0 is 1. 4 to the first is 4.
that's our parent function right now
let's look at the transformations
let's now you want to make sure this is
one thing I haven't pointed out but that
the K value this negative 3 over here
you're going to want to do that
transformation last you could do the
horizontal shift next or you could do
this vertical stretch or Shrink next
either one is fine you're going to get
the same result I'm going to go ahead
and do this vertical shrink by one half
which is going to multiply all the Y
values by one half
cross out the old ones then the x minus
3 is going to shift the graph remember
the one group of the X has the opposite
effect it's going to shift it right 3
which means I'm going to add 3 to all
the X values cross out the old ones the
minus 3 is going to shift the graph down
3 which means I'm going to subtract 3
from all these uh
y values so that's going to be let's see
negative 1 negative two and a half and
negative 2 and 7 8. so if I plot these
points Let's see we have 2 and negative
2 and 7 8 which is right about there
3 and negative two and a half which is
right about here
and 4 negative 1 which is right about
here and we have a horizontal asymptote
at y equals negative three that's this K
value
okay so you can see that the graph here
now is looking something like
this
and notice we know it's an exponential
growth because our base is
greater than one
the one-half was like a vertical shrink
and then we shifted it right three and
down three and so that's how we're
getting the graph there the domain is
going to be all real numbers the range
is going to be Y is greater than
negative 3. so great job if you're able
to follow these three examples if you
want more practice graphing exponential
functions follow me over to a previous
video I did right there and we'll get
some more practice I'll see over in that
video